[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public c'est parti
pour 90 minutes de débat et de reportage
et c'est une édition spéciale que je
vous propose aujourd'hui pour les 1 an
de la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron
s'était le 24 avril 2022 pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
Cinquième République hors cohabitation
un président est réélu et pourtant ce
soir là on ne sent pas le souffle de
l'euphorie c'est la guerre en Ukraine et
le candidat sortant annonce des jours
difficiles
alors il nous reviendra ensemble devrait
cette unité par laquelle seul nous
pourrons vivre plus heureux en France et
relever les défis qui nous attendent
les années à venir à coup sûr
ne seront pas tranquilles
un an après quel premier bilan peut-on
tirer de ce second quinquennat pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas su ou pas voulu
tirer les leçons des législatives de
juin 2022 peut-il redonner du souffle à
notre République fatiguée on va répondre
à toutes ces questions et à d'autres
avec des historiens des politologues des
constitutionnalistes et des journalistes
qui ont enquêté dans les coulisses d'un
second mandat jusqu'ici bien terne en
comparaison de l'énergie des premiers
mois de 2017
et pour lancer ce premier débat on se
rafraîchit la mémoire retour sur une
année de réforme et de fracture avec
Samia de chien
le 24 avril 2022 Emmanuel Macron est
réélu pour un nouveau mandat fort de
58,5% des suffrages le président célèbre
une victoire marquée par une percée
inédite de l'extrême droite je sais
aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte
mais pour faire barrage à celle de
l'extrême droite
et je veux ici
les remercier
et leur dire que j'ai conscience que ce
vote m'oblige pour les années à venir
deux mois plus tard c'est la douche
froide au législatives la majorité
présidentielle n'obtient que 245 sièges
de députés Emmanuel Macron ne dispose
pas de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale premier revers politique suivi
par une crise climatique à l'été 2022 la
France s'embrase les incendies se
multiplient sur fond de canicule et de
sécheresse à la rentrée le président
sonne la fin de l'abondance ce tableau
que je fais là cette fin de l'abondance
cette fin de l'insouciance cette fin des
évidences montre que c'est au fond une
grande bascule que nous vivons
face à laquelle évidemment nos
compatriculteurs peuvent réagir avec
beaucoup d'anxiété à l'automne la Russie
suspend ses exportations de gaz vers
l'Europe les prix de l'énergie explosent
et alimentent une spirale inflationniste
la France entre dans une aire de
sobriété et d'instabilité politique
privée de majorité absolue le
gouvernement n'est pas en mesure de
faire adopter le budget de l'État ni
celui de la sécurité sociale par dix
fois Elisabeth borne va devoir dégainer
le 49-3 pour les faire adopter sans vote
la France a besoin d'un au 1er janvier
2023 et le temps presse désormais aussi
sur le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 un contexte explosif pour
l'examen de la réforme des retraites qui
s'avérera impossible à l'Assemblée
nationale le 19 janvier la première
manifestation rassemble plus d'un
million de personnes coups d'envoi d'une
mobilisation massive qui plonge le pays
dans une crise sociale et politique
toujours en cours Emmanuel Macron
promettait une méthode renouvelée de
dialogue mais la première année de son
second mandat aura surtout creusé un
fossé grandissant entre lui et les
Français
voilà 90 minutes de débats et de
reportage autour des 1 an de l'élection
de la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron et
dans ce premier débat on va plutôt
regarder derrière nous dans le
rétroviseur faire le bilan de cette
première année avec Sophie Cognard
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste au Point hauteur de la
tyrannie de la médiocrité publiée aux
éditions de l'Observatoire j'accueil
Frédéric Daby bonsoir le directeur
général opinion de l'Ifop Jean garrigue
bonsoir Monsieur historien président du
comité de l'histoire parlementaire et
vous publiez Elysée contre Matignon de
1958 à nos jours c'est aux éditions
Taillandier et Mathilde Siro éditoris
politique bonsoir Mathilde bienvenue à
vous aussi je rappelle les conditions de
la victoire d'Emmanuel Macron le 24
avril 2022 il l'emporte avec
58,55% des suffrages exprimés Marine Le
Pen avec suit avec 41,45 en nombre de
voix Sophie Coignard tiens si on essaie
de se rappeler ça est-ce qu'il est bien
élu est-ce qu'il est mieux que
5 ans il a progressé en fait je parle
sous le contrôle des vrais
professionnels
je dirais qu'il a engrangé un million de
voix en gros de plus que qu'en 2017 donc
de ce point de vue oui et des pas n'est
pas encore en échec à ce moment-là et la
question de la légitimité parce que ça
va être ça aussi le le thème un peu
central de notre premier débat elle se
pose déjà pourtant
se pose à partir
législatifs sont quand même enfin un
énorme moment de
d'étonnement et de stupéfaction
on n'a pas moi je me souviens très bien
que au moment même personne ne tire
vraiment toutes les leçons et toutes les
conséquences
qu'on voit aujourd'hui à devenir mais en
tout cas c'est quand même comment vous
dire ça brise tous les mantras qu'on
avait en tête c'est à dire que depuis la
réforme institutionnelle du quinquennat
et donc c'est législatif qui suivent la
présidentielle tout le monde avait
considéré comme acquis que
évidemment le pays donné une majorité au
président qu'il venait délire première
chose et deuxième chose souvenez-vous
des débats qu'on a depuis des années sur
la proportionnelle l'injection de la
proportionnelle dans dans l'élection les
élections législatives ben là on n'a pas
eu besoin de proport mais c'était
sincèrement c'était inenvisageable
c'était inimaginable donc là tout à coup
on a dû enfin tout le monde y compris
les principaux acteurs de cette de tout
cela ont dû changer de logiciel ou du
penser autrement et donc ça a été pour
moi le résultat des
législatives a été effectivement un
séisme politique et j'allais dire
presque intellectuel Frédéric d'abbition
si on se replonge le soir de sa
réélection
c'est une soirée particulière est-ce que
la question de la légitimité elle se
pose déjà pour vous je trouve déjà
intéressant que cette question se pose 5
millions de voix ce n'est pas rien c'est
un des écarts les plus importants soit
5e République je mets de côté 2002
prenons remontons encore plus loin en 74
Giscard d'Estaing en porte de moins de 1
million de voix 50 points 9 il vient
septennat extrêmement dur la gauche de
l'époque François Mitterrand Georges
Marchais ne l'épargne pas mais jamais
aucun des deux jamais un leader
socialiste j'aime un leader communiste
ou radical de gauche parle de Giscard
d'Estaing comme un président mal élu
illégitime à l'Élysée c'est un discours
qu'on a entendu j'ai envie de dire le
soir du second tour au début de la
campagne avec un joli Mélenchon qui
efface la présidentielle en demandant
d'être élu premier ministre donc la
légitimité se pose alors même que il a
progressé entre son premier tour de 2017
et son premier tour de 2022 5 millions
de voix c'est extrêmement fort il a
gagné peut-être pas par KO comme en 2017
mais il a gagné nettement le débat avec
Marine Le Pen qui en pense seulement à
un moment au moment où elle parle du
pouvoir d'achat où elle est plus elles
sont plus au contact des préoccupations
des Français mais cette légitimité s'est
posée pourquoi je pense que c'est pas le
score c'est pas l'écart de voix c'est
des conditions de l'élection c'est cette
campagne tronquée c'est cette campagne
qui a été à rebours de l'imaginaire des
Français sur traditionnellement en ce
moment le cathartique ou les Français
regardent un spectacle présidentiel des
candidates des candidats qui présentent
l'offre leur offre électorale qui compte
campagnes en quelque sorte elle a été
phagocytée par le covid on oublie qu'il
y avait encore des restrictions jusqu'en
février 2022 et elle a été anesthésiée
par l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine et
donc les conditions de cette élection
cette campagne tronquée ont eu des
conséquences kmitesuses d'abord une
sorte d'apathie après sa victoire avec
une très un temps infini pour désigner
son gouvernement et une absence de
surprise pas de ministre waouh le si je
peux si je puis dire maintenant on sait
Catherine Vautrin paquetine Vautrin ils
avaient de borne et puis le la poursuite
du gouvernement des experts que les
Français ne voulaient pas ça explique
aussi cette campagne législative à
moitié ratée et ce que dont Sophie vient
de parler alors ce qui est quand même
frappant Jean garrigue c'est que je l'ai
dit moi en amorce en titre c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
Cinquième République hors cohabitation
qu'un président est réélu et ça j'ai eu
le sentiment mais presque le soir même
je me souviens on présentait la soirée
électorale ici même que c'était à peine
évoqué ou balayer en quelques ou
quelques minutes ou en quelques heures
c'est un des grands paradoxes le
paradoxe de cette élection qui aurait pu
être considéré comme un triomphe
historique puisque inédit et qui
apparaît en fait y compris dans les mots
de la reconnaissance par Emmanuel Macron
de ce qui s'est passé au deuxième tour
comme finalement un demi succès je
nuancerai un tout petit peu la la
campagne tronquée j'ai pas eu
l'impression que la campagne était
tronquée et celle du président a été
tronqué mais pour le reste n'oublions
pas toute l'aventure Éric Zemmour et
tous les débats internes à toutes les
autres parties du du monde du monde
politique donc c'est celle du président
de la République il manquait le entre
guillemets le principe le principal le
pour que la confrontation soit totale
soit complète quoi et c'est ça qui a été
qui était tranquille et donc d'emblée
c'est un affaiblissement pour pour lui
il y a effectivement la remise en
question de sa de sa légitimité et il y
a cette ce questionnement sur le sur le
deuxième tour et au regard de ce qui
s'est passé pendant la crise des
retraites cette idée où il reconnaît que
au deuxième tour il a été élu par des
gens qui ne partagaient pas son
programme quand on sait qu'au moment de
cette crise des retraites le principal
argument de de sa de sa forme
d'autoritarisme ou d'un transit ça a été
de dire justement mais vous m'avez élu
sur mon programme sur sur la question
des retraites il y a une contradiction
c'est intéressant parce qu'on l'a
entendu mais rapidement dans le dans le
sujet d'ouverture de Samia et de
chiffres je vous propose de réécouter ce
passage du discours d'Emmanuel Macron
donc le soir de sa victoire on est au
Champ de Mars effectivement il
intériorise cette question de légitimité
on écoute je sais aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
je veux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote m'oblige pour les
années à venir
je suis dépositaire de leur sens du
devoir de leur attachement à la
République et du respect des différences
qui se sont exprimées ces dernières
semaines
qu'on se souvienne de ce qui s'est passé
avant ce discours d'Emmanuel Macron
Sophie cognat je suis sûr que vous avez
ça en tête on a on a retrouvé un peu le
timing c'est-à-dire que l'annonce de
l'élection il est 20h évidemment on a
les scores mais quelques minutes après
on a marine Le Pen puis Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui prenne la parole ça
n'était là aussi jamais arrivé
c'est-à-dire normalement on laisse au
Président je sais pas un temps de d'état
de grâce enfin c'est sa soirée ou même
c'est sa semaine jusqu'à la cérémonie
d'investiture enfin bon voilà les
perdants faut profiter pas du tout et ça
c'était frappant là aussi sur la
question de la légitimité dont on parle
dans ce débit de débat oui c'est ce qui
se passe quand on infracturé la droite
de gouvernement et la gauche de
gouvernement
c'est pour faire c'est pour faire une
petite pirouette mais c'est complètement
lié effectivement l'opération des
légitimations vous avez raison elle a
lieu aussi dans ces dans ces petits
symboles en même temps ce qui me semble
inouï quand on revoit ses images pas
seulement quand on écoute mais quand on
revoit c'est à quel point ce président
réélu vous mentionnez tout à l'heure la
performance qui consiste en effet à être
le seul l'unique il l'a en tête et donc
il a forcément en tête le fait que ça va
bien se passer pour la suite autrement
dit c'est un discours qui mange pas de
pince qu'il fait s'il avait une majorité
absolue il veut dire dire ça m'oblige je
penserai à vous tous ou moins dit je ne
suis plus le le candidat d'un camp je
suis le président on a toujours on lui
oppose aujourd'hui
au combien Jean gariga a raison mais si
on se remet comme vous le dites dans le
dans le moment particulier
évidemment ce président nouvellement
réélu car forcément en tête qu'il a
réussi un truc que d'autres ont ratés ne
peut pas envisager qui va se prendre une
terrible veste dans quelques semaines et
donc par conséquent cette cette petite
comment dirais-je ce petit geste
d'ouverture élégant ne paraît pas à
l'époque avoir de grosses conséquences
politiques me semblent-ils
quelques jours après le deuxième tour il
y a un sondage Frédéric doit savoir ça
mieux que moi mais si je me souviens
bien ou je crois que plus de 60% des
Français souhaitent une cohabitation le
soir même notre sondage
ça ça pouvait être quand même un petit
indice de ce qu'elle est le va arriver
parce que ça même au lendemain de
l'élection de Jacques Chirac en 2002 on
parlait pas de cohabitation on parlait
éventuellement d'un d'une alliance d'un
contrat de gouvernement avec avec la
gauche des choses qui dont on a peu
parlé d'ailleurs au moment de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron mais cette idée là
qu'il faudrait lui mettre un
contre-pouvoir législatif elle apparaît
très très vite alors David vous publiez
pour SUD RADIO un sondage sur les les
traits d'image associés à Emmanuel
Macron et il est aujourd'hui il est il
est passionnant il en ressort quoi bah
il est assez dévastateur parce qu'il
s'inscrit dans la durée c'est pas un one
shot si je puis dire dans le cadre de
cette période difficile que connaît
Emmanuel Macron on a commencé à poser ce
type de questions en 2018 pour les 1 an
de son anniversaire c'est clair c'est
une dégradation tous azimut de l'image
Emmanuel Macron les deux premiers
tradings qui lui sont associés c'est
autoritaire 68% il vous inquiète 62% et
puis sur des attributs essentiels de la
panoplie présidentielle il y a un
véritable effondrement est-ce qu'il est
attaché aux valeurs démocratiques on
voit des traces de la réforme des
retraites 33% moins 15 par rapport à
2022 entre parenthèses il y a deux le
même tradimage associé à Marine Le Pen
50% des français disent Marine Le Pen
est attaché aux valeurs démocratiques
est-ce qu'il est compétent il est à 36%
moins 12 je vais pas donner tous les
chiffres est-ce que il est capable de
rassembler les Français dans un contexte
de seconde mandat François Mitterrand en
88 la France unie est entre parenthèses
en parlant de la presse le titre de
libération le soir la victoire de
François Mitterrand le lendemain c'est
chapeau d'artiste en étant réélu une
deuxième fois rien de tel pourrait même
Macron capable de rassembler les
Français 17% moins 18 Marine Le Pen est
à 59%. on voit qu'elle arrive à
construire une image en décalque de
celle d'Emmanuel Macron et que sur tous
les trads testés il y a il faut le dire
un véritable effondrement loin de
l'équation personnelle sympathique en
rupture avec les stéréotypes
traditionnels associés au personnels
politiques est-ce qu'ils défend les
intérêts de la France un item plutôt
gentil pour un président 35% moins 12
par rapport à 2022 tout est on voit très
bien à quel point c'est cette année
horribilis cette réforme des retraites
classiques dans le sens où le président
paye le prix de l'impopularité donne une
structure d'image qui rappelle une fin
de règne le problème c'est que c'est pas
une fin de règne on n'est pas en 2016
pour François Hollande ou en 2011 pour
Nicolas Sarkozy il reste 4 ans de
mandats et c'est pour ça que ce débat
est passionnant on cette partie là se
projeter dans l'après et dans les quatre
années on le fera plutôt en seconde
partie mais je voudrais revenir quand
même sur ce trait
autoritaire qui est le plus important
qui arrive en premier Jean Gary est-ce
qu'on dit pas est-ce qu'on disait pas ça
de tous les présidents de la 5e
République d'une certaine façon est-ce
que le poste ne crée pas le sentiment
d'autoritarisme il a été conçu comme tel
il faut pas se le cacher par le général
de Gaulle tailler à sa mesure sauf que
l'autorité pour le général de Gaulle
venait de sa propre histoire de son
prestige d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle il a recherché à partir d'une
962 l'élection auprès du président
suffrage universel pour lui donner ce
surcroît de légitimité et et d'autorité
mais on ne le disait pas de François
Hollande ça lui va coûter cher aussi de
ne pas être assez autoritaire c'était
une valeur que les électeurs de
d'Emmanuel Macron lui en ont toujours
accordé massivement c'est même quelque
chose qui était positif on peut dire il
y a les deux traits il a de l'autorité
51 %. voilà
il a de l'autorité il était à 73% en
2018 il passe à 51 il est autoritaire il
est maintenant son premier trait d'image
l'autorité lorsqu'elle dérive en
autoritarisme se retourne contre un
président de la République dans une
société précisément où la valeur
d'autorité est de plus en plus contestée
il y a vraiment quelque chose de
culturel aussi là-dedans qui qui est
conduit à une contestation à mon sens de
ce qu'est la sur-présidentialisation de
du régime c'est à dire qu'au-delà de du
caractère la personnalité de Macron il y
a une contestation de ce que de ce que
joue du rôle que joue un président de la
République mais c'est aussi quelque
chose de culture l c'est à dire que
l'autorité dans notre société qui
demande plus d'horizontalité en tout cas
dans les jeunes générations c'est
quelque chose qui passe mal et on voit
bien et d'ailleurs le lectorat
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est plutôt des
seniors c'est des gens pour qui
l'autorité c'est une valeur qui est plus
importante que pour d'autres générations
Macron qui assume son impopularité
petite faire autrement c'est ce qu'il
disait hier lors de sa visite bousculée
en Alsace ici à Sélestat
la mission d'un président de la
République n'est ni d'être aimé de ne
pas être aimé c'est d'essayer de faire
bien pour son pays et d'agir et moi je
suis au service des Françaises et des
Français
je serai jusqu'au dernier instant du
mandat qui m'ont confié et je le serai
par beau temps et par temps de pluie
qu'il neige ou qu'il vendent et s'il
pouvait y avoir quelques jours de beau
temps ça me dépérirait pas mais s'il
doit y avoir beaucoup de ventes et
beaucoup de beaucoup de pluie je le
ferai quand même
alors derrière ces références
météorologiques Sophie Coignières il y a
évidemment le président des cris celui
qui tient la barre dans la dans la
tempête il dit pas ça par hasard
évidemment c'est peut-être ce qu'on
retiendra quand même de ces mandats le
président des crises il me semble que
c'est une enfin on a on voit bien qu'il
a pas tellement d'atouts dans sa manche
c'est un de ses atouts quand même c'est
d'essayer de rappeler enfin comme je
trouve qu'il le fait bien enfin je
trouve que ça cette séquence est assez
réussi en termes de communication non
non cette petite ce petit bout que vous
passez enfin moi j'avais remarqué je
m'étais dit tiens on retrouve enfin vous
savez avec une sorte de séquence
nostalgie on retrouve le Macron 2017
avec cette espèce de fraîcheur qui l'a
quand même beaucoup perdu l'exercice du
pouvoir
use terriblement donc c'est assez réussi
et en même temps c'est effectivement un
message politique
important c'est à dire
souvenez-vous qui je suis je suis le
gars qui avait son son surligneur à la
main pour
pour surligner les études en anglais
faites sur le covid parce que je voulais
pas croire les experts etc donc je
m'occupais de vous en ligne direct si
j'ose dire sans passer par les experts
etc et ce qui veut dire la c'est
exactement ça c'est
quoi qu'il arrive je tiendrai c'est la
contraposée de ce qu'il dit
lundi soir dans son allocution sur
Notre-Dame c'est en fait c'est c'est
dire c'est délivrer autrement le même
message c'est le président protecteur et
c'est vrai que pendant la crise covid il
y a peu d'états en Europe qui ont autant
aidé leur concitoyable donc et comment
dirais-je et un décourageable oui oui ça
j'entends ça et bon on va pas ouvrir ça
débat mais comme souvent d'ailleurs
quand un pouvoir politique donne quelque
chose bon bah c'est les citoyens ne lui
en font pas forcément crédible mais ça
c'est un autre c'est un autre sujet vous
voulez prendre la parole Mathilde on
était en train de parler de
l'impopularité de la dégradation de
l'image d'Emmanuel Macron avec vous
Frédéric Daby cependant elle reste il
reste garde un socle autour de lui
autour de sa personne et de sa politique
peut-être davantage que qu'un François
Hollande d'ailleurs est-ce que le moment
dans lequel on est on peut parler de
cassure du de l'opinion vis-à-vis
d'Emmanuel Macron et est-ce que pour
vous c'est irréversible au contraire il
peut encore remonter la pente alors
c'est vrai vous avez raison de rappeler
que contrairement aux Français Hollande
de la loi travail qui devient même
minoritaire chez les sympathisants
socialiste je parle pas de ce son
électorat du premier tour du 22 avril
2012 Emmanuel Macron garde son socle son
socle c'est érodé il avait jusqu'à
l'automne 90% de de satisfaction dans le
baromètre JDD auprès de ces électeurs du
10 avril du premier tour il n'est plus
qu'à 75%. ça reste comment dire élevé et
dans l'enquête que j'ai présenté sur les
traits d'images pour SUD RADIO sauf sur
la proximité aux préoccupations des
Français des majoritaires est très
majoritaire dans son somme donc le socle
tient maintenant est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron peut rebondir je veux pas faire
de prédiction j'ai envie de dire lors du
premier mandat il a déjà rebondi trois
fois ce qui n'était jamais arrivé pour
un président hors période de
cohabitation de connaître trois rebonds
significatifs aux tonnes 2017 avec le le
vote des doigts sur le code du travail
il arrive une partie de la droite il
redevient majoritaire poste gilet jaune
le grand débat le parti de l'ordre le
rempart Emmanuel Macron face à la
chanlie il gagne une quinzaine de points
et il assure à son parti un score très
honorable aux élections européennes et
troisième rebond vous en parliez le
covid où il se passe un truc un truc pas
bon quelque chose de jamais vu sous la
Cinquième République pendant deux ans sa
cote de popularité ne bouge pas elle
reste à 40% dans le baromètre JDD 45
dans le baromètre de bonnes opinions du
baromètre match parce que il y a une
sorte de classique de popularité c'est
le président des crises le capitaine
dans la tempête et fait d'un côté par
rapport à la guerre en Ukraine le
président protecteur il est sorti de
cela complètement il paye le prix
classique d'un président en situation de
crise d'une impopularité le rebond j'ai
envie de dire pour l'instant à court
terme je ne vois aucunement parce que
pour les Français la page des retraites
n'est pas soldée et oui il voudrait la
tournée le mécontentement sous la
réforme il reste de la rancœur sur le
chagrin alors on est en train tous
ensemble de faire le bilan de cette
première année du second quinquennat
Macron et on va grâce à table à nuit se
tourner vers un bilan évidemment
parlementaire bonsoir
l'activité législative depuis un an oui
si on fait le bilan on peut distinguer
trois temps ou plutôt 3 catégories de
textes il y a d'abord les textes ou la
stratégie de construire une majorité
texte par texte n'a pas trop mal marché
on va y revenir ensuite vous avez les
textes budgétaires loi de finance 2023
budget de la Sécurité sociale 2023 qui
ont été adoptés à coup de 49,3 à
l'Assemblée nation mais sans que ça
aille meuf grand monde parce que c'est
un peu la règle normale quand on est
dans l'opposition on peut pas voter ce
type de texte et puis il y a le grand
crash de la réforme des retraites là
encore un texte budgétaire aussi adopté
par 49-3 mais pas du tout avec les mêmes
conséquences pour le coup très contesté
et par l'opposition et par une bonne
partie des Français sur la réforme des
retraites il a évidemment un effet
aveuglant on a tendance à oublier qu'il
y a eu des majorités de projets qui ont
été construites sur certains textes et
oui ce quinquennat a commencé avec une
nouvelle donne une mauvaise nouvelle
pour le président de la République la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale vous en avez parlé et tout de
suite ça a fait beaucoup gloser sur la
difficulté à faire passer des réformes
mais en réalité au départ le
gouvernement n'a pas tout de suite été
paralysée il y a eu 11 projets de loi
définitivement adoptés tantôt avec le
concours de la droite sur l'assurance
chômage par exemple ou la loi locmi sur
les moyens du ministère de l'Intérieur
tantôt avec le concours de la gauche par
exemple la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables tantôt avec le concours de
la droite et d'une partie de la gauche
par exemple le projet de loi sur la
relance de nucléaire adopter grâce aux
voix et l'air et communiste à
l'Assemblée il y a aussi eu 12
propositions de loi qui sont également
passées par miel des textes plutôt
consensuels comme la proposition de loi
pour apporter une aide d'urgence aux
victimes de violence conjugales ou celle
qui vient encore en aide aux élus qui
sont menacés 23 textes et une méthode
avec laquelle Elizabeth borne voudrait
renouer après le débat ou le sur les
retraites écoutez le président de la
République m'a chargé d'engager un
travail avec tous les parlementaires qui
veulent agir pour notre pays nous en
sommes capables nous l'avons montré
encore récemment en bâtissant des
majorités de projets autour de la loi
sur les énergies renouvelables ou encore
hier à l'Assemblée nationale sur le
nucléaire évidemment ce ne sera pas si
simple de retrouver cette état d'esprit
avec le Parlement et oui les week-end
dernier la première ministre a déclaré
vouloir accélérer accélérer sur les
réformes mais quelle réforme le
calendrier parlementaire c'est vidé d'un
coup après la loi sur les retraites
l'immigration sujet hautement
inflammable devait être débattu au
Parlement mais le texte a été mis en
pause face à l'absence de majorité on a
évoqué l'idée de saucissonner le texte
pour voter les mesures de durcissement
avec la droite les mesures de
régularisation avec la gauche cette
option elle a depuis été écartée mais le
président de la République a bien mis le
sujet à l'agenda des 100 jours c'est ce
qu'il a dit lundi il l'a dit nous
renforcerons le contrôle de
l'immigration illégale tout en intégrant
mieux ceux qui rejoignent notre pays sur
le projet de loi immigration et bien le
gouvernement continue de compter sur LR
la droite c'est allié peut sur versatile
on a vu comment ça s'était terminé sur
les retraites du coup et bien l'exécutif
n'a toujours pas trouvé la recette le
Parlement est toujours à l'arrêt alors
que le gouvernement parle d'accélération
il va encore falloir trouver l'embrayage
merci beaucoup Tom Sophie Coignières je
lis j'entends depuis plusieurs jours que
ce gouvernement est le plus faible de
l'air Macron est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord
de donner des bonnets et des mauvaises
notes mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
objectivement il y a assez peu de enfin
il y a beaucoup de ministre fantômes
donc c'est pas comment dirais-je ça
n'est pas un atout majeur dans une
période de explique aussi la difficulté
à imprimer peut-être dans l'opinion des
des réformes qui sont passées au
Parlement et qui sont restés un peu sur
les sous les radars médiatiques ou en
tout cas dans l'opinion oui bien sûr et
puis enfin au-delà de la question de
personnes ça pose j'allais dire la
question de confiance c'est à dire que à
partir du moment où vous avez un
gouvernement composé pour plus de moitié
je pense quand on demande enfin quand on
fait des sondages de notoriété il y a
plus de la moitié des des ministres les
deux tiers voilà qui qui sont connus que
de leurs parents et de leurs voisins en
gros enfin j'exagère un peu c'est un peu
ça un petit peu donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que l'idée
d'équipe gouvernementale enfin
Elisabeth borde la sortie les rames
depuis longtemps pour essayer
d'expliquer qu'elle est à la tête d'une
équipe elle est pas à la tête d'une
équipe Elisabeth borde ou alors elle est
à la tête d'une équipe extrêmement
restreinte donc la plupart des gens qui
sont en position de d'être effectivement
fort et audible sont des gens qui
voudraient sa place ou celles d'Emmanuel
Macron donc si vous voulez faut
reconnaître que la configuration n'est
pas tout à fait optimale quand même
effectivement on peut on peut dire ça là
depuis donc à la suite de son allocution
lundi soir il y a donc cette stratégie
d'aller sur le terrain depuis deux jours
on l'a vu d'abord en Alsace aujourd'hui
il était dans dans l'Hérault à porter
dans le lieu d’engueulade comme dit
c'est ses soutiens il faudrait qu'il a
dit est-ce que ces séquences où ils se
confrontent à des Français
en colère et c'est sans doute ce qui
cherche aussi en allant sur le terrain
est-ce que ça peut le relancer en tout
cas dans une partie de l'opinion en tout
cas c'est pas une surprise pour les
Français il a toujours faire ça avant
même son élection comme président de la
République sa première grande sortie
médiatique 2014 Europe 1 les ouvrières
de Gad qui n'ont pas le permis et qui
sont même il est très petit au lait il
s'excuse quelques jours après il va sur
le terrain et il se confronte il n'a
jamais eu peur d'aller au contact on
n'est pas sur la logique des années
Sarkozy en 2011 où il y avait des
villages protéines ou les centres-villes
étaient un peu vidé il y avait des
UMP qui venaient on n'est pas là dessus
c'est vrai que ça peut donner à voir un
président
courageux qui n'a pas peur d'aller au
contact il fait de la pédagogie ça fait
un peu campagne présidentielle d'entre
deux tours parce que c'est vrai que je
lance sur ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
la campagne d'entre deux tours a été
plus une vraie campagne puisque
Emmanuel Macron est allé beaucoup sur le
terrain mais ça donne aussi à voir le
spectacle si je puis dire d'un président
discrédité détester insulter même
insulter enfin en fin de course alors
que je le répète on est sur le début du
mandat par rapport à ce que disait
Sophie cuire il y a pas une équipe
gouvernementale qui l'entoure le fait
d'avoir pas sacrifié mis fin au
gouvernement des experts qui étaient une
attente forte en 2017 mettons un sportif
une sportive au sport un médecin à la
santé et un DRH à l'emploi les Français
attendent plus d'incarnation que quand
je pense à l'intervention présidentielle
de lundi il détaille les deux sujets qui
sont au cœur de la préoccupation des
Français santé éducation je mets de côté
l'inflation et le poids d'achat on
rajoute le grand âge le logement on est
sur 4 ministres complètement inconnus
des Français sans doute avec des grandes
qualités mais qui n'ont pas réussi à
incarner politique et pas assez
politique ça fait vraiment un président
qui donne qui met en scène le spectacle
d'un certain isolement je voudrais qu'on
reparle sur ces de ces 100 jours avec
votre regard historien parce que alors
on a tout de suite la référence
napoléonienne évidemment qui nous qui
nous vient en tête très heureuse pour
pour Napoléon
mais il y en a une autre qui nous vient
des États-Unis il faut peut-être la
rappeler ah oui c'est celle Franklin
Roosevelt élu
triomphalement en novembre
1932 et puis qui prend son pouvoir en
mars 33 et là il lance effectivement un
programme de 100 jours alors articuler
sur ce qu'il appelle Newdeal pour
redresser la barre dans un monde une ce
qu'on appelle la Grande Dépression de
des États-Unis et il lance un programme
de 100 jours qu'il impose au congrès à
marche forcée où il y a je sais plus une
quinzaine de lois qui vont être votées
et des lois qui en plus sont qu'on
appelait omnibus parce que à l'intérieur
de chaque loi il y avait au moins 10 ou
20 une douzaine de de sous lois c'est à
dire une frénésie législative qu'on n'a
jamais connu d'ailleurs même aux
États-Unis c'était quelque chose
d'unique il y a une grande différence
sauf qu'il le fait tout de suite alors
et qu'il a la majorité surtout alors
voilà c'est toute la différence c'est
que il le fait d'abord sur un programme
identifié avec un Brent trust enfin des
types très de grande qualité qui était
claire c'était une rupture avec ce qu'il
avait été élu pour ça c'était une
rupture pour ça il était il avait un
grand prestige ce qui n'est plus le cas
d'Emmanuel Macron il était très
populaire Franklin Roosevelt et puis il
avait une majorité au Congrès et les
moyens d'imposer sa volonté au Congrès
exactement l'inverse de la situation de
d'Emmanuel Macron donc le concept des
100 jours si vous voulez si on regarde
du côté de Napoléon ça se termine par
waterlooel c'est complètement différent
alors il y a un homme politique français
qui est arrivé au pouvoir à parler de
100 jours c'est Dominique de Villepin il
arrive en 2005 après la catastrophe du
29 mai exactement les raisons de le dire
il annonce il promet qu'en 100 jours il
pourra faire reculer le chômage et il y
arrive plus ou moins et sacré un petit
effet dans l'opinion une effervescence
auprès auprès de lui on peut voir un
rival aux Nikos Sarkozy qui apparaissait
omnipotent et incontournable à droite
bon il finit par se fracasser sur le CPE
un an après mais ce n'est pas le seul
qui avait utilisé alors ce qui est
intéressant de dans ce débat et sur la
question de la légitimité j'y reviens
c'est que pendant la cette première
année de Seconde quinquennat Mathilde
tout de suite presque les questions sur
la succession d'Emmanuel Macron il vient
à peine d'entamer son second quinquennat
que les questions sur sa succession elle
se pose déjà tout le monde s'interroge
sur la prime Macron oui Thomas il reste
quatre ans et pourtant il y a déjà deux
questions principales qui tarauent tous
les esprits dans le camp du président
alors la première est-ce que le
macronisme survivra à son créateur à
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 les
opposants au chef de l'État à Paris sur
une chose qu'en marche ou Renaissance
désormais ne soit qu'une parenthèse
vouée à se refermer assez rapidement
alors depuis 6 ans certes le président a
vous avez élu mais sa structure
partisane elle reste fragile il patient
toujours d'un déficit d'ancrage et d'une
absence de doctrine idéologique claire
la deuxième question qui se pose
essentiellement dans son spectre
politique c'est qui serait à même de
battre Marine Le Pen ou quelqu'un du
rassemblement national dont la victoire
est présentée comme inéluctable en 2027
alors à date évidemment il reste
beaucoup de temps il n'y a aucune
évidence sur cette question Édouard
Philippe dispose d'un avantage sondage
et je parle sous le contrôle de Frédéric
Daby Bruno Le Maire n'a pas renoncé à
l'idée de retenter sa chance et Gérald
Darmanin rêve bien sûr de devenir
Président comme François Bayrou ils sont
déjà nombreux on n'a pas de successeur
naturel ou d'héritiers voilà c'est tout
le problème qui va se poser ces
prochains mois et ses prochaines années
la compétition entre les ambitieux vase
bien sûr s'intensifier au risque
peut-être de virer à la guerre
fratricide certains du coup au sein la
majorité pour éviter le scénario
suicidaire de la division pousse auprès
d'Emmanuel Macron pour qu'il prépare sa
suite ou qu'il organise sa succession
pour qu'au moins il y ait un processus
de désignation plus ou moins clair qui
soit actée pas trop tard le président
d'ailleurs s'y était engagé dans un
dîner en présence de ses principaux
ministres et cadres de la majorité
c'était le premier septembre il avait
dit ma responsabilité c'est que Marine
Le Pen ne gagne pas en 2027 il s'était
posé en garant de la suite pour son camp
alors est-ce qu'il est le mieux placé
pour organiser l'après on se souvient
que par le passé ça n'a pas forcément
réussi par exemple François Mitterrand
avait voulu propulser Laurent Fabius à
la tête du PS et c'est finalement Pierre
Moreau qui avait mis la main sur sur
Solférino cela pourrait être davantage
la prérogative du parti Renaissance mais
encore une fois le problème c'est que
cet appareil partisan a été pensé dans
le bureau du président alors c'est
compliqué pour penser pour imaginer cet
après Macron la tripartition du paysage
politique oblige pourtant l'espace
central à régler les éventuelles
divergences et désaccords en interne et
en amont pour ne pas se retrouver
écartés par les deux autres blocs en vue
d'une présidentielle reste une question
pas sûr que le dépassement des clivages
qui a été le succès d'Emmanuel Macron
dans sa conquête du pouvoir en 2017 soit
toujours la recette magique pour 2027
l'espace politique du macronisme peut
survivre à Emmanuel Macron c'est la
question effectivement qui se pose quand
on a un parti présidentiel qui n'est peu
connu des Français est-ce que le
macronisme peut survivre Emmanuel Macron
l'avenir le dira en tout cas il y a pour
l'instant deux héritiers assez nettement
identifiés Mathis 0 l'a très bien dit
celui qui est dehors Édouard Philippe
qui est la seule personnalité politique
qui a une majorité de bonnes opinions
sur 50 ans dans le baromètre il faut
Fiducial pour parer match et SUD RADIO
ils c'est 17 avoir une majorité de
bonnes opinions en 2012 8 en 2017 ça
raconte l'histoire de la défiance à
l'égard du personnel politique et c'est
une sorte de Pompidou 68 69 sauf qu'il
aura pas 10 mois il aura 4 ans à tenir
pour éventuellement être candidat et
l'emporter et puis il y a peut-être
celui qui est dans le comment dire dans
le dans le chaudron à savoir Bruno Le
Maire qui est le ministre le plus
populaire du gouvernement Macron du
gouvernement borne avec juste après lui
Gabriel Attal il faut pas lui prêter de
l'ambition présidentielle mais c'est le
peut-être la seule personnalité inconnue
en 2017 qui existe clairement auprès des
Français donc il y a ces deux démarches
là alors puisque l'espace central et
central quid des LR qui ne rentre pas
dans la tripartition vous avez évoqué
Mathilde est-ce que l'espace central ne
sera pas au final faut du fait de la
faiblesse des héritiers du macronisme du
parti Renaissance
occupé par quelqu'un de chez ADR
personne ne peut écarter même si ça
paraît un peu incongru aujourd'hui cette
hypothèse dans le bilan de cette
première année de Seconde mandat Sophie
Cognard je voudrais qu'on dise un mot
des relations entre Emmanuel Macron et
son ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe ça ne s'est pas arrangé on peut
on pourrait dire ça on peut même
sûrement dire que ça n'est pas
arrangeable
pourquoi pourquoi ça s'arrangerait et ce
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
sans vouloir psychologiser tous et le
caractère de ces deux hommes la deuxième
c'est que aujourd'hui
quand vous voulez devenir président de
la République est-ce que être associé à
Emmanuel Macron de manière positive
avoir le soutien l'affection publique
d'Emmanuel Macron est un énorme plus la
formule de l'orphelie pardon je vous
interrompre c'était le loyal mais libre
ou quelque chose comme ça c'était
je crois que c'était dans l'autre sens
peut-être c'est
important le sens des mots c'est
important effectivement mais voilà c'est
ça donne un peu sa stratégie pour les
pour les années à venir ce qui est enfin
jusqu'à présent il joue pas trop mal le
coup parce que moi je me suis demandé
par exemple si
surtout le dans toute la séquence
de duel verbal entre Laurent Berger et
Emmanuel Macron Édouard Philippe
n'allait pas devenir une victime
collatérale de ce duel pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement il fut un temps où la
CFDT soutenait une réforme des retraites
menées par Emmanuel Macron
souvenons-nous c'était au moment de
l'instauration enfin de la volonté
d'instaurer un système universel par
point d'accord c'est un projet qui était
depuis longtemps porté par la CFDT et je
ne m'égare pas tout à fait par réparer
Philippe parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand est-ce que tout à coup
Laurent Berger ce type coopérant etc
collaboratif voire rouge c'est quand tes
doigts Philippe mais sur la table là je
pivot et là ça rend pardon ça ça rend
vraiment Laurent Berger un peu dingue
hier parce qu'on a consacré
en tête effectivement il est en colère
on le voit vraiment et je me suis enfin
et il était il était pas totalement
délirant de se dire mais tout à coup il
va être rattrapé par cette histoire
parce que tout le monde va se dire mais
alors ces relations elles viennent d'où
et cetera et qui est le qui est le
personnage qui a mis vraiment le feu
dans les relations entre Macron et
berger que il y a d'autres variables
mais c'est quand même Édouard Philippe
et aujourd'hui on est sur les 64 ans des
gens dans la rue etc il y a quand même
un personnage quelle époque était
premier ministre qu'à parler de ces de
ce nombre aujourd'hui body de 64 ans
c'était Édouard Philippe et par une
sorte de je ne sais pas de miracle pour
lui pour l'instant il me semble qu'il
s'en sort complètement ADEME de cette
histoire
il y a d'abord une constante sous la
Cinquième République c'est que les
présidents détestent avoir des
successeurs à tous ont voulu brûler leur
successeur de Gaulle avec avec Pompidou
s'ils deviennent plus populaires que
exactement
mais François Mitterrand et Lionel
Jospin enfin bref à chaque fois ils
essaient donc euh il est pas sûr que
manolocamp fasse tout pour aider ses
successeurs moi je pense que la logique
c'est-à-dire presque historique c'est
que la macronie ce qu'on appelle la
macronie ensemble explose et que ceux
qui ce qui en ressortent puissent être
d'un côté un candidat de la droite d'une
droite plus classique c'est-à-dire un
Édouard Philippe par exemple ou un autre
mais qui a aussi qui est aussi une
partie de gauche qui mordent qui puisse
de la gauche
qui soit une gauche sociale démocrate
pourquoi parce que non seulement la
macronie est appelée à mon sens à
exploser mais aussi la nupesse on voit
très bien déjà toutes les tensions qui
est qui opposent les différentes membres
de la nups on a vu la rencontre entre
Fabien Roussel et Bernard Cazeneuve bref
il y a des éléments à mon sens pour que
dans cet espace là justement que cet
espace même à la limite s'élargissent
mais que surgissent deux autres familles
qui comme par hasard serait les familles
qui nous ramèneraient à l'avant 2017
parce que le macronisme comme son nom
l'indique c'est un peu comme le
gaullisme c'est lié à Emmanuel Macron le
gaullisme a réussi à se survivre parce
qu'il y a eu des dauphins plus ou moins
alors justement plus ou moins dissidents
mais qui ont réussi à s'imposer des
charismes nouveaux qui ont reçu à
s'imposer il y a eu Pompidou il y a eu
Chirac et puis Nicolas Sarkozy là moi je
vois difficilement quelqu'un sortir du
sérail macronien pour incarner justement
cet avenir merci beaucoup merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat je vais rappeler les titres de vos
livres respectifs Sophie Coignières la
tyrannie de la médiocrité livre publié
aux éditions de l'Observatoire
pourquoi il faut sauver le mérite et
puis Jean garrigue bah c'est exactement
ce que vous étiez en train de nous
raconter il disait contre Matignon de
1958 à nos jours aux éditions Talandier